[Música]
dos misiles rusos impactaron quiére
durante la visita del secretario de la
onu antonio guterres quien se reunió con
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr se la
skip ellos discutieron la evacuación de
militares y civiles que continúan en la
asediada ciudad de mariupol
se avecina un cambio de gabinete en
francia el jueves se realizó el que iba
a ser el último consejo de ministros
pero la próxima semana se volverán a
encontrar por la reelección de manuel ma
con la reunión fue un termómetro de
quién podría ser el próximo primer
ministro
ya son más de 20.000 los pandilleros o
integrantes de las maras que han sido
capturados en el salvador desde que fue
decretado el estado de excepción el
gobierno dice que es para reducir la
hora de asesinatos pero defensores de
derechos humanos denuncian más de un
centenar de detenciones arbitrarias
bienvenidos a france24 hoy a toda la
información de la actualidad mi nombre
es maría clara calle y empezamos con las
noticias de ucrania dos misiles
sacudieron el distrito central de ser 5
en kiev uno de ellos golpeó los pisos
inferiores de un edificio residencial de
25 plantas y dejó al menos 10 heridos
los bombardeos ocurrieron horas después
de que el secretario general de las
naciones unidas antonio guterres se
reuniera con el presidente volodymyr
selenski en la capital ucraniana
guterres se mostró sorprendido por el
ataque pues aseguró que la ciudad es
sagrada tanto para los ucranianos como
para los rusos mientras que se les
condenó el hecho
y eso dice mucho de la verdadera actitud
de rusia hacia las instituciones
mundiales sobre los esfuerzos de los
dirigentes rusos para humillar a la onu
y todo lo que la organización representa
los ovnis tras su cita con volodymyr
selenski antonio guterres afirmó que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin accedió
en principio a que la onu y la cruz roja
internacional evacúen civiles de
mariupol el secretario de naciones
unidas además recorrió algunos pequeños
pueblos destruidos cerca de la capital
esto ocurre el mismo día en el que el
gobierno de eeuu le pidió al congreso
que apruebe 33 mil millones de dólares
de ayudas adicionales para quién
antonio guterres se reunió con volodymyr
ce lens quien quiere el representante de
naciones unidas aseguró que estaba
haciendo todo lo posible para permitir
la evacuación de más de 1000 civiles y
de cientos de combatientes en la planta
de azov tall and not going to no voy a
entrar en ningún comentario que pueda
socavar esa posibilidad de expositores y
la enorme siderúrgica es el único
bastión que aún resiste en el puerto de
mariupol mayoritariamente en manos de
los rusos que aseguran que los civiles
pueden abandonar la planta pero los
combatientes tendrán que deponer las
armas selenski volvió a insistir en que
está preparado para hablar de la
situación en el puerto de azov y
denunció los continuos ataques a mumbai
vemos que a pesar de las palabras del
presidente ruso sobre el supuesto fin de
las acciones de combate en mariupol el
territorio de asof tal está siendo
bombardeado bárbaramente por el ejército
ruso antes del encuentro guterres visitó
las localidades de buche y boro de anca
allí recordó que son siempre los civiles
quienes pagan el precio más alto más
temprano selenski se reunió también con
su homólogo búlgaro kiril petkoff
acordaron apoyo para transportar la
producción con la de ucrania
principalmente granos a través del
puerto de varna en el mar negro y un
suministro de armas a ucrania petkoff
también visitó el ping donde aseguró que
está en disposición de cortar su
dependencia del gas ruso
nunca planeamos estar sin gas ruso hace
solo unos meses pero ahora tenemos
opciones y estamos comenzando a
desarrollar una estrategia alternativa
si somos capaces de hacerlo todos en
europa deberían poder hacerlo en orkut y
devotos web al otro lado del océano el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
sumo apoyo con una nueva solicitud de
fondos
sánchez que acabo de firmar una
solicitud al congreso de asistencia
crítica en materia de seguridad
económica y humanitaria para ayudar a
ucrania seguir contrarrestando la
agresión de putin en total 33 mil
millones de dólares de los que 8 mil 500
millones irán destinados a ayuda
económica directa para que no colapse la
economía ucraniana la petición de joe by
there al congreso de eeuu ocurrió horas
antes de que los legisladores
respaldarán a la casa blanca y es que el
congreso aprobó una legislación que
facilitará la exportación de armas a
ucrania la llamada ley de préstamo y
arriendo ya fue usada antes para ayudar
a derrotar a adolf hitler y ahora la
cámara aprobó la medida para respaldar a
ucrania y como el senado ya la había
pasado antes sólo falta la firma de joe
biden para que entre en vigencia
pasamos a francia porque debido a que el
presidente de manuel marco fue reelegido
el jueves no fue el último consejo de
ministros de la actual administración el
día final del gobierno iba a ser el 13
de mayo pero ahora el actual gabinete se
reunirá otra vez la próxima semana y
antes de la formación de un nuevo grupo
de ministros para el segundo mandato
quién se queda quién se va la llegada
del consejo de ministros el jueves fue
una oportunidad para hacer predicciones
sobre la composición del próximo
gobierno en cualquier caso los actuales
miembros deberán servir presentes la
próxima semana ya que en el primer
quinquenio de manuel ma con no termina
oficialmente hasta el 14 de mayo
el gobierno está en su tarea de seguir
tomando las decisiones necesarias para
la protección de los franceses y de
todos los temas de actualidad
sin embargo el nombramiento de un nuevo
primer ministro cambiará la situación se
especula sobre quién será el sucesor de
jan castex la personalidad elegida
deberá dar el impulso deseado por macrón
de cara a las elecciones legislativas de
junio mientras tanto la consigna sigue
siendo la misma desde la victoria del
presidente saliente el pasado domingo
la elección de los franceses que es una
elección histórica es una elección que
nos obliga y requiere que se tomen
decisiones importantes sobre el fondo
pero también sobre una nueva forma de
gobernar de implicar a los franceses en
la decisión de dar vida a la ciudad
la política prometida en 2017 estaría
por tanto a punto de aplicar se podría
comenzar durante la primera quincena de
mayo cuando se espera tenga lugar la
ceremonia de investidura presidencial
no ha comenzado el verano boreal de
manera oficial sin embargo india y
pakistán están padeciendo una ola de
calor sin precedentes lo que ha
provocado cortes de electricidad escasez
de agua e incendios nueva delhi la
capital ha presentado temperaturas de
hasta 46 grados centígrados según los
pronósticos la ola de calor se extenderá
por 5 días y afectará al noroeste y al
centro de india cerca de 1400 millones
de habitantes presentan una disminución
del abastecimiento de agua una situación
que se espera que cambie con las
llegadas de las lluvias monzónicas entre
junio y julio el gobierno de najib
bukele en el salvador defiende el estado
de excepción diciendo que en el mes de
la medida ya se han capturado más de
20.000 pandilleros el presidente la
decretó argumentando una lucha contra el
repunte histórico en la ola de
asesinatos se convirtió en el presidente
que más integrantes de las maras ha
detenido a nadie buque el informó que
desde el inicio del estado de excepción
se han capturado a más de 20.000 nuestra
policía nacional y fuerzas armadas han
superado las 20.000 capturas inicio de
la guerra contra las pandillas hasta las
7 de la noche de este día el total de
terroristas capturados es de 20 mil 290
en sólo 33 días bukele dijo también que
ya son seis días consecutivos sin
homicidios los arrestos preocupan a las
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos como human right watch
amnistía internacional y christos al
esta última el jueves denunció que se
han registrado detenciones arbitrarias
durante el estado de excepción entre
otras vulneraciones
sólo cristo sala ha atendido casos de
147 personas detenidas arbitrariamente
identificándose además tratos crueles
inhumanos degradantes y reiteradas
violaciones de las garantías judiciales
mínimas en los procesos iniciados bajo
el estado de excepción quedan
suspendidos varios derechos
constitucionales como de defensa
libertades de asociación y reunión entre
otras el congreso del salvador aprobó el
domingo una extensión al estado de
emergencia decretado el 27 de marzo la
constitución de ese país establece que
para ampliar el régimen de excepción
debe cumplir con un periodo máximo de 30
días y mantenerse las mismas
circunstancias que lo originaron en este
caso la ola de asesinatos en este país
centroamericano se registraron a fines
de marzo 62 homicidios en un día la
cifra más alta de las últimas dos
décadas el presidente buque le aseguró
que las detenciones continuarán que el
salvador tuvo en el 2019 la tasa de
homicidios más alta por habitante del
mundo vuelve la feria del libro de
buenos aires esta edición número 46
regresa luego de haberse suspendido en
los últimos tres años a causa de la
pandemia el que es uno de los eventos
culturales más importantes de américa
latina se realiza durante 19 días y
tendrá más de 1.500 actividades nuestro
corresponsal en argentina- natalio cosoi
habló con ezequiel martínez director
general de la feria del libro y esto fue
lo que le dijo después de tres años de
no haberse realizado en toda su historia
está la edición 46 2020 fue la primera
vez que se tuvo que suspender y generó
una expectativa una ansiedad unas ganas
de reencontrarse que creo que eso se va
a traducir en una feria absolutamente
masiva y multitudinaria como
ha sido pero potenciada por esta todas
estas características hasta aquí las
noticias gracias por elegirnos
[Música]